foreign
there is still a lot of incoming and
it's getting close
[Music]
the flooding of hairson has been a new
layer of Crisis a potential War crime
playing out in real time in front of the
world's eyes
600 square kilometers of land just in
Harrison region itself was plunged
underwater as the war continued with
smoke plumes of recent strikes still
visible
Ukrainian Emergency Services already
stretched scrambled to rescue mostly
elderly people stranded in their homes
mainly Ukrainian volunteers pulled to
safety household pets
and they rushed to save farm animals no
creature seen as too small to try to
save this was ecocide said the Ukrainian
president
he denounced what he called the shameful
indifference by key Global players in
responding to this major catastrophe
and amongst those fleeing was a growing
number from the russian-occupied Left
Bank of kherson who spoke of Looting of
shelling as they tried to escape and
their sheer relief of making it out
alive
when we were in dachi all our boats had
been sunk she says and they were looting
our summer houses and our boat engines
they were taking everything our guys
just managed to save the two boats
others told us how many of the Russian
troops were themselves stranded and left
to fend for themselves
the Russian soldiers told us they were
expecting to be evacuated all it tells
us but when the help didn't come they
just started swimming
the Ukrainian president warned the lack
of fresh waters now going to be an
ongoing problem and sharply criticized
the restricted access to the
russian-controlled areas with drones
being used to drop supplies to those now
trapped by water
all these trees are submerged the houses
the whole of the basement and the first
floor has gone
and you can hear the sound as they're
still trying to defend themselves the
bus stop where people used to to stop
and and try and get buses is now pretty
much completely submerged
the Ukrainian leader visited one of the
few evacuation points at Hess on and
severely criticized the lack of
worldwide response saying International
organizations have forgotten how to save
lives
hours after the president leaves as yet
Moore managed to make it across from
russian-held Land the sounds of War were
getting closer and closer
your home your home she's saying but
they've hardly had time to catch breath
before there's another attack
this time it's much closer the Russians
on the other side have pinpointed the
few flood rescue areas the attack seems
to be deliberately aimed at this
evacuation point and there's sudden
Panic with everyone scrambling there's
been incoming call now and all the
evacuation operations have had to
scatter All The Rescuers back to the
scatter and just even these people just
waiting all just headed for shelters and
buildings some are still holding the
creatures they've rescued
many of these people are already
traumatized amongst them those who are
trying to help during this huge
emergency
body armor was hastily put on by eight
volunteers taken by surprise
but they're attacked again
[Applause]
even as they try to save their few
emergency supplies there is still a lot
of incoming and it's getting close so we
might have to retreat certainly a lot of
the rescue workers the few that we hear
have scattered wildly and said that's it
for today they're basically just packing
up now and they're still coming under
attack on water it's worse
a relief effort rescuing the stranded
and vulnerable from a deliberate
flooding now being repeatedly targeted
it's hard to imagine it getting much
more frightening for these people
yeah
there's been incredible bravery with
these volunteers despite being under
Fire and now carrying injured still
pushing through and steering those most
in need to dry land and safety
the swollen denipro River and flood zone
is now being punctured by multiple
attacks
the rescue area where the Ukrainian
leader was earlier is also bombed
we were given this footage by a soldier
rushing another injured civilian to
safety
but still the attacks continued forcing
the frail and elderly to shelter but not
crushing their determined spirit
they bombed our apartment before New
Year she tells us we've been through it
all I'm not afraid of anything anymore
the damn explosion has Unleashed an
environmental catastrophe with the Water
full of sewage tons of oil and toxic
chemicals
there are already signs of the terrible
toll it's taking on the land and nature
a nearly 200 kilometers away in Odessa
the roofs of homes and broken Utility
Equipment has been washing up on the
coastline
the torrent of water cascading from the
dam has destroyed thousands of homes
with hairson residents forced to watch
as their cities destroyed again
I don't know what to do lidmiller says
how can they do that okay it's War
soldiers are fighting each other but to
blow up the hydroelectric Dam I can't
find the words it's Barb Barrack she
finishes
the people of kherson City have been
occupied and they're still being bombed
and shelled so deliberate flooding isn't
phasing them when you live here for more
than six months after being bombed all
the time after being scared all the time
so it's scary but not so much as you're
bombed all the time
foreign
to stay safe
but the flooding and attacks on the
rescue operation have brought a fresh
level of shock and Terror to a war where
so much has horrified already
Alex Crawford Sky News in Pearson
Southern Ukraine